A new technology called "PulseWallet" syncs your credit card to the palm of your hand.
Using a biometric palm reader, this cardless payment service allows you to pay...
...by simply scanning your veins; giving a whole new meaning to blood money.
PulseWallet seems to have the upper hand on other NFC payment systems.
For example, unlike Google Wallet, where you scan your phone for payment,..
...PulseWallet doesn't require you to present anything to make a transaction,...
...other than yourself.
The system was unveiled at CES in Las Vegas...
...and will reportedly go on sale in February.
Something tells me it will have businesses eating out of the palm of its hand.